[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau grand jt des territoires sur aux
chaînes locales et régionales et sur tv5
monde
voici les titres de l'actualité une
innovation majeure pour la santé des
bébés prématurés une nouvelle technique
qui permet de traiter différemment les
malformations cardiaques explications
dès le début de ce journal avec la
rédaction de via occitanus une
exclusivité dans ce grand jt des
territoires marc lavoine le coach de the
voice nous a reçus pour nous parler de
cette émission que tout le monde ou
presque regarde le samedi soir
portrait de mathilde didelot la jeune
femme est devenue la nouvelle miss curvy
lorraine un concours de beauté est une
miss qui veut changer le regard sur les
rondeurs rencontre aussi en fin de
journal avec le nouveau gardien du
temple du rhum clément en martinique
après 20 ans de service
julien team on devient maître de chai de
la maison son parcours avec la rédaction
devient atv martinique sur place je vous
le disais dans les titres l'hôpital des
enfants du chu de toulouse a développé
une nouvelle technique innovante pour la
prise en charge de malformations
cardiaques chez les bébés prématurés
près de 20% des grands prématurés
souffre d'un canal artériel persistant
avec cette nouvelle technique plus
besoin d'opération les explications avec
ce sujet de geoffroy priol pour vie
occitanie sur place ce petit bouchon de
quelques millimètres est une révolution
dans la prise en charge des bébés
prématurés
il permet une technique innovante pour
traiter une malformation cardiaque
le canal artériel persistant et cette
nouvelle technique a pu être réalisé
pour la première fois dans le grand sud
à l'hôpital des enfants du chu de
toulouse
il s'agit d'aller fermer le canal
artériel qui est une communication que
vous voyez ici sur un quai l'imprimer en
3d bien évidemment zoomer entre deux
vaisseaux l'aorte et l'artère des
poumons
le but est donc de fermer ce canal
artériel que régis fermé à la naissance
comment ça se déroule on passe par la
veine du nouveau-né au niveau du pli de
la jambe
on pique la veine ce aux échographies et
ensuite le plus doux possible moins
invasif on vient juste
petits vaisseaux et on vient mettre ce
bouchon car si ce canal artériel ne se
referme pas il peut être dangereux pour
le bébé
il ya 20 % des nouveau-nés prématurés
qui vont garder ce canal artériel ouvert
on le ferme quand il est de taille
importante et donc il va gêner vraiment
le nouveau-né surtout donc amené
beaucoup de sang aux poumons et donc
déjà des poumons immatures et fragile et
donc le but c'est d'aller les protéger
en fermant le canal artériel ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'avant il fallait
opérer ses enfants et donc ouvrir le
thorax à faire une cicatrice sur le
thorax et ouvrir sur des bébés très
fragiles déjà qui nécessitait ensuite
beaucoup d'anti douleurs des jours en
dormi parce qu'il y avait une chirurgie
alors que là on va juste passer un petit
cathéter par les vaisseaux pour pouvoir
ensuite déployé ce petit bouchon un
premier bébé né à 25 semaines et pesant
800 g a pu bénéficier de cette opération
au mois de décembre grâce à la
collaboration entre plusieurs services
et maintenant l'objectif pour le docteur
clément karsenti c'est de réaliser ce
type d'intervention au moins dix à vingt
fois par an nous vous en parlons souvent
dans son jt des territoires la détresse
psychologique des étudiants inquiète
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
afin de mieux les repérer et de les
aider le conseil départemental du val
d'oise finances dans le cadre du plan
jeunes une formation aux premiers
secours santé mentale cette formation
doit être dispensée à 90 étudiants de
six cergy paris université d'ici 2022
romain et humains pour vyas 95 étudier
tout en étant confiné
c'est la dure réalité vécue par les
vingt-cinq mille étudiants de cergy
depuis plus d'un an maintenant le
premier confinement ça allait encore
parce que c'est tout était nouveau on
connaissait pas la chose est pendante le
deuxième confinement gelé très très mal
vécu et j'ai pensé arrêter mes études il
ya de ça trois mois parce que j'avais
beaucoup de mal à suivre les cours
j'avais plus de motivation et j'avais
beaucoup de mal à me projeter dans
l'avenir et pour détecter ce ballet
qui de mieux placé que les étudiants
eux-mêmes secondes de volontaires suit
une formation aux premiers secours en
santé mentale d'origine australienne
ce programme étalé sur deux jours est
encore très peu répandue en france
la formation est entièrement financé par
le département du val d'oise à hauteur
d'environ 25000 euros
quand j'entendais des personnels de
d'écoles d'universités ils me disent on
a des jeunes au téléphone qui sont
suicidaires cette dernière qui disent je
ne sais plus où je vais je dois plus
personne c'est plus possible et c'est
vrai que avoir des jeunes qu'ils soient
formés à les écouter à les aider c'est
extrêmement important c'est même capital
fraîchement diplômé paul adrien 21 ans
est désormais plus attentifs aux signes
avant coureurs l'étudiant en troisième
année de droit a pris à dérouler un plan
d'action en cinq étapes
intitulé aéré pour approcher écoutez
réconforter encourager renseigné nom /
je vais pas repéré à quelqu'un qui
marche si oui ou non il a atteint de
troubles psychiques mais c'est sûr que
maintenant je me sens capable en une
discussion à peu près normal de se
sentir c'est une personne va se
renfermer sur elle
vis-à-vis d'un trouble de savoir si au
contraire tout va bien au total 90
étudiants de siwa et cergy par et
universités vont pouvoir en profiter
gratuitement d'ici 2022
la seconde main est l'une des grandes
gagnantes de cette crise sanitaire
depuis l'arrivée de lakovic 19 et
surtout déconfinement la vente de
vêtements déjà portés explose sur
internet une deuxième vie pour nos
habits qui satisfait les vendeurs mais
aussi les acheteurs reportage dans la
loire d'adrien bletterie pour tl7 je
prends souvent séduit tant ce geste
beaucoup le maîtrise de plus en plus
aujourd'hui la seconde main est l'une
des grandes gagnantes de cette crise
sanitaire
depuis l'arrivée de lakovic 19 et
surtout déconfinement la vente de
vêtements déjà portés explose sur
internet déjà j'ai commencé par vendre
c'est clair et par contre je pense que
c'est très addictif donc c'est mon gros
problème
je suis acheteuse compulsive donc en
fait bah ouais là voilà j'ai acheté un
sweat à capuche un polo un dvd
j'ai vendu des soutiens les achats
peuvent vite devenir compulsif mais la
vente
elle permet de recycler lithium
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'ils ont c'est
toujours agréable de faire un petit peu
de sous c'est clair mais après mangement
très bas très bas prix pour pour que ça
parte
le but c'est d'avoir la de faire plaisir
à d'autres personnes et puis c'est ultra
rapide quoi mais d'autres profitent de
la deuxième main pour économiser jusqu'à
80% sur plusieurs articles
donc quand on achète un pantalon à 4
euros au lieu de 35 forcément ça fait
des grosses économies à la fin du mois
moi c'est ce qui m'a motivé c'est que
luc et magasins sont fermés
automatiquement
ça fait toujours du bien de pouvoir
acheter le diable on va en bon état et
pas cher c'est pourquoi il a changé pas
eu des jets pas eu de regret au niveau
de mes achats
tout le monde trouve son compte et même
les friperies profite d'un changement de
mentalité effectivement les gens
viennent de plus en plus à consommer
autrement c'est un peu dans l'air du
temps
oui j'ai de nouvelles clientèles après
la clientèle est très large du coup un
ça va de l'étudiante à la retraités en
passant par la femme active du recyclage
de dépenses moindres des petites
attentions
merci beaucoup d'avoir acheté dans mon
placard j'espère que cette fondation
vous plaira papy veine ty martin ah bah
voilà je trouve que ça c'est super sympa
espérons que cela dure quand la crise
sanitaire sera terminé il n'est pas le
plus connu de france mais n'en est pas
moins exceptionnelle le viaduc de vior
est un ouvrage d'art ferroviaire unique
au monde construit en 1902 dans la
vallée où coule la rivière éponyme qui
sépare le tarn et l'aveyron le peau
métallique a marqué les esprits par son
architecture novatrice toujours en
activité avec 18 passages de trains par
jour
ce viaduc est aussi une curiosité
touristique
il est d'ailleurs entré depuis 2018 dans
une démarche de classement au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco pas moins avec cinq
autres ponts métalliques européen
explication micro de manon aussi pour le
journal de la dépêche du midi nos
partenaires sur place
l'ingéniosité qu'il avait c'était de
relier ces deux ces deux arches ces 2,2
milliards sh sept métiers jamais vu
quant au monde c'était la première fois
qu'on voyait ça et puis surtout que ces
retenues après sur des quatre plots et
c'est tout cas c'est vraiment
c'est extraordinaire comme conception
nous entrons dans une démarche de
classement au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
avec cinq autres pays européens si on
obtient ce classement au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
nous aurons aussi une reconnaissance
mondiale
et ça c'est quoi ça sera le summum en
sortir le champagne et je crois c'est
l'heure de notre rendez vous éco région
avec vous ou michele picot bonjour c'est
certainement la dernière usine en france
à fabriquer du fils de soie pour la
haute couture mais pas seulement vous
allez nous présenter aujourd'hui
l'entreprise au ver à soie elle
s'appelle ces bureaux sont installés au
coeur de paris dans un ancien quartier
du textile son usine elle elle est
située près de chambord depuis plus de
200 ans maintenant michel bonjour sert
il bonjour à vous tous le saviez vous
depuis 1820 la petite entreprise
artisanale au ver à soie fabrique et
commercialise pour les professionnels du
fil à soi pour tous les usages broderie
haute couture dont elle maroquinerie et
même pour la pêche à la mouche
si le siège est à paris au coeur de ce
qui fut le quartier du textile leur
usine est située à bracieux près de
chambord la sonatur elle vient elle de
chine meilleurs pays éleveurs de vers à
soie au monde mais les files sont
fabriqués en france depuis plus de 200
ans est la cinquième génération de la
famille fondatrice la famille boucher
qui est aux commandes aujourd'hui la
qualité de leur fils leur permet de
parler de leaders du fis la soie mais au
delà du fil pour la haute couture ils
ont su inventer pour les amateurs de
pêche à la mouche la marque pêche à soie
ou encore la tresse pour les bijouteries
mais comment trouver de la soie de
qualité me direz vous cela dépend de
l'élevage des bombes x les bombyx sont
les vers à soie si vous préférez et
attention au delà de l'alimentation
c'est à dire des feuilles de mûrier les
séries si twitter ce sont les éleveurs
de vers à soie nous préviennent des
dangers auxquels sont exposés ces fameux
ver l'aboiement d'un chien le chant du
coq une odeur nauséabonde peuvent
déranger les verts fraîchement éclos
les larves doivent reposer sur des
matelas c'est qu'elles doivent dormir
manger travailler en harmonie enfin les
verts
cheminées et somnolent doivent être
chatouiller avec une plume de poulet
afin de stimuler leur croissance
on comprend effectivement mieux pourquoi
ce fil est un produit de luxe
merci michel picaud on se retrouve dans
un prochain grand jt des territoires
sans transition à 31 ans la spinalienne
mathilde didelot kinésithérapeute est
devenue la nouvelle miss curvy lorraine
une expérience et un message à porter au
nom de toutes les femmes corpulentes
acquis et réserver ce concours de beauté
le rendez-vous pour l'élection de miss
curvy france et déjà donné à bordeaux
reportage de la rédaction de via vosges
à epinal au moins toutes ses fidèles
aventure elles comprennent elles ont
vécu un peu ces choses un concours de
beauté réservé aux femmes rondes pour
les aider à se sentir mieux dans leur
corps c'est l'opportunité qui a saisi la
spinalienne mathilde et didot
à 31 ans elle devient miss curvy
lorraine 2021 le 25 avril à yutz moselle
la jeune femme a défilé dans quatre
tenues différentes avec onze autres
participantes
une expérience qu'elle n'imaginait pas
vivre il ya encore un an je pensais pas
qu'ils existent et des concours pour les
femmes
voilà qui correspondent pas aux normes
de beauté et quand j'ai vu que ça
existait bas j'ai pas réfléchi j'ai tout
de suite envoyé mon mail des normes de
ce concours exclu seul condition pour y
participer
faire une taille 42 ou plus je pense que
ces normes sont désuètes tout simplement
elles représentent des critères que
certaines personnes ont décidé de m et
c'est pour ça que c'est important
avec le concours miss curvy de montrer
d'autres images d'autres morphologie
montrer qu'à pâques une femme qui rentre
dans les critères de beauté qui en a
plein dans son dressing mathilda une
majorité de vêtements qui met en avant
sa féminité une revanche face aux
moqueries qu'elle a subies adolescente
lors de ce concours à l'issue duquel
elle a été sacrée miss curvy lorraine
pas de champ public en raison des
conditions sanitaires
le comité les courbes de lorraine a dû
se résoudre à organiser un défilé
virtuels ce qui n'a pas empêché la jeune
kinésithérapeute d'être très soutenue je
suis que se présenter à
misco lorraine je les soutenais alors à
plein pot mes collègues masculins l'ont
plutôt charrier c'était leur façon a eu
le lui montrer que c'était derrière elle
et puis moi je lui ai déjà dit que
j'aurais pas été capable de faire ce
qu'elle a fait donc là dessus je suis
fière d'elle voit toutes les femmes qui
peuvent se reconnaître dans mon parcours
j'ai vraiment envie de leur dire d'être
moins durs envers soi même parce que
souvent on est les plus durs avec notre
corps de prendre du recul et s'accepter
tel qu'on est prochaine étape pour la
spinalienne le concours miss curvy
france il devrait se dérouler d'ici la
fin de l'année du côté de bordeaux
elle aussi se bat pour une autre image
des femmes et affichent leur colère dans
les rues du mans depuis bientôt deux ans
le collectif collage féministe le mans
vient exposer sa 100ème affiches dans
les rues de la ville un événement
symbolique pour leur combat lutter
contre le sexisme ordinaire qui peut
aboutir au féminicide le reportage de
laurent girard pour vyas lmtv sartre sur
place c'est avec conviction mais aussi
dans un état d'esprit ludique que ces
jeunes femmes collent leur 100e affiche
féministe au mans ces moments émotions
on est profond
n'est ce pas on n'aura plus que 100 et
qu'il y en aura encore beaucoup beaucoup
et n'a pas besoin de beaucoup de
réfléchir même si on passe juste
quelques secondes devant on comprend
assez bien le
pas lui ce que ça veut dire d'expérience
elles savent que ces textes sont
rapidement arraché par les passants si
ça tient pas très longtemps au moins il
ya une trace sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est partager et même ceux qui n'ont
pas vu dans la rue parce qu'il passait
pas par là bas ils pourront le voir ça a
commencé à part me sens les réseaux
sociaux nous on n'aurait peut-être pas
su on aurait pas fait au mans à travers
ses collages aux textes souvent
provocateur elle souhaite avant tout
créer un électrochoc dans les
consciences
si ça provoque
tant mieux ça choque ça fait réfléchir
c'est surtout ça le but
le collectif du mans est composée de
près 2 40 colleuse pour la plupart âgés
d'une vingtaine d'années en général
elles utilisent les panneaux
d'expression publique prévue à cet effet
mais pas toujours quitte à être dans
l'illégalité
c'est plus percutant et ce à une
dimension de prise de possession de
l'espace public dans lesquels les femmes
et les minorités d'or sont très peu
présentes en tout cas on a souvent
tendance en tant que femme aux minorités
de genre à se sentir en danger dans ce
pass publics défendent des femmes qui
peuvent mourir par exemple sont par
contre l'effet monstre c'était important
qu'à mer les confinements successifs ont
incité ses colleuse à agir au grand jour
pour ne pas déroger au couvre-feu
elle assume mais a conscience de prendre
un risque supplémentaire au cours de
notre reportage quelques insultes et
autres noms d'oiseaux sont sortis de
voitures passant à proximité de ce
groupe de chimie
comment remédier à la fracture numérique
qui touche nos campagnes en corse la
mutualité sociale agricole a initié un
projet novateur la mise en circulation
d'un bus connecter une première en
france celui ci permet aux habitants
d'effectuer par exemple des prises de
rendez vous avec de nombreux partenaires
de france service un accompagnement sur
le numérique et un suivi des adhérents
dans toutes les branches de la sécurité
sociale sont aussi proposer une nouvelle
offre essentiels notamment pour les
personnes âgées qui sont ainsi
accompagner gratuitement dans leurs
formalités administratives précision
d'albane gingembre de la rédaction de
giat et les prises et sur place en corse
l'idée ici aujourd'hui avec ce bus c'est
d'amener le service public
chez les gens là où il y en a le plus
besoin
là où il n'y en a pas aussi bien d'un
point de vue administratif que en termes
d'offre de soins parce que nous ici on a
rien donc
quand on a besoin de vraiment d'un
dernier tous deux trucs comme ça ne
serait ce que faire un billet de bateau
simplement
eh ben ça c'est formidable la gironde
est le premier département français en
nombre de départs de feux de forêt pour
les contrer une technique écologique est
en train de se développer l'agro
pastoralisme
le dispositif consiste à faire paître
des moutons dans des parcelles de forêts
pour qu'ils nettoient en fait le solde
végétaux très combustible dans la forêt
de biganos sur le bassin d'arcachon les
450 brebis attendu arriveront le mois
prochain
mais sur place gestionnaires d espaces
verts et exploitants se prépare à
biganos donc reportage de baptiste monge
et pour la rédaction de télé 7 la chaîne
du groupe sud ouest
cinq mille hectares de forêt dans
lesquelles seront placés 450 brebis en
s'installant ici c'est le défi que
relève virginie bergère de l'aude
thyssen région de coeur pour moi que je
connais très bien aussi avec ses grands
pins et voilà on vient là en se disant
qu'on contribue à la lutte contre
l'incendié fait que les brebis pâture
réouvre les milieux maintiennent voilà
une forêt avec une végétation
on a pu clair possible afin que si
éventuellement il y en a cent dix à se
propage humain possible les moutons
réduisent aussi l'impact carbone du lieu
en remplaçant des outils mécaniques pour
l'entretien de la forêt mais leur
premier rôle sera de brouter les
buissons et feuillages combustible qui
bordent les sentiers et moutons vont
pouvoir avoir un apport revenant
consommer tout ce qui est notamment la
strate herbacée vous voyez là tout c'est
toutes ces herbes là qui sont très
problématiques en terme d' incendies de
forêt puisque le feu s'y propage très
rapidement et les brebis vont également
pouvoir entretenir toute la partie herbe
sur les pistes
le maire de biganos se donne deux ans
avant de juger l'efficacité de
l'agropastoralisme
mais il est convaincu de ses avantages
l'expérimentation un double avantage
c'est d'abord ça va entretenir la forêt
et le bordure des pistes forestières et
les fossés et le deuxième c'est ça ne
coûte rien les brebis qui s'installeront
ici auront du travail la gironde connaît
en moyenne près de mille feux de forêts
par an c'est un succès d'audience tous
les samedis soir la 10e saison de the
voice touche presque à sa fin
émission doit sa réussite populaire à
ses talents bien sûr mais aussi à la
personnalité de chacun de ses coachs
parmi eux marc lavoine l'artiste conclut
sa deuxième saison sur le fauteuil rouge
et le grand jt des territoires a eu la
chance de rencontrer
l'occasion de lui demander directement
les raisons du succès de l'émission
écoutez sa réponse au micro de
christophe rigaud en exclusivité pendant
cinq ans comme animateur the voice
c'est une émission où les gens viennent
d'en faire entendre leur voix
c'est un studio de travail la sotra que
vous avez jamais vus ya quatre ou cinq
courses à 17 ans dans sa fuite ont pu
vite je fais de la chanson 182 j'ai
commencé à chanter et j'ai jamais eu
l'occasion de jouer avec des ciments
musiciens la télé des six grands
techniciens sont des gens qui sont sur
toutes les scènes de france et les
meilleurs techniciens son et un
technicien lumière mais remaquille
relais cadreur il va pas les caméras me
rase et à la scène au centre nous le
public derrière nous quand il l'a eu
avec les conditions sanitaires c'est
plus compliqué mais il est là quand même
et puis au centre une scène et donc
c'est vraiment une configuration c'est
comme un cirque
on ouvre une page d'histoire dans ce
grand jt des territoires avec notre
invité jérôme cordelier bonjour jérôme
bonjour vous êtes le rédacteur en chef
chargé du service politique du magazine
le point
mais aussi l'auteur d'un livre enquête
l'espérance est un risque à courir c'est
son titre
ce livre part à la rencontre des
résistants chrétiens pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale alors qu'est ce qui vous
a amené du journalisme politique vous à
vous intéresser à la religion vous êtes
l'auteur de plusieurs livres sur ce
sujet ben c'est chemin faisant en
exerçant mon métier de
de journalistes et de reporter tout
simplement donc en allant en voyageant
en se déplaçant un peu partout en france
je me suis aperçu que on a une mémoire
important de la religion dans ce pays
je trouve intéressant en plus de
naviguer entre le spirituel et le
temporel
donc la politique ce sont des affaires
très temporelles mais c'est intéressant
aussi de donner un petit peu de
supplément d'âme de chair à ce que nous
faisons jérôme cordelier dans votre
dernier ouvrage vous avez mené une
enquête dans toute la france et jusqu'à
jérusalem pour témoigne est ces
chrétiens catholiques protestants
orthodoxes aussi qui ont résisté aux
nazis pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
ce sont pour vous des acteurs méconnus
de l'histoire au fond oui c'est un pont
oubliés de notre histoire c'est à dire
qu'on a beaucoup mis l'accent sur la
résistance française et notamment sur la
aussi sur la résistance communiste à bon
droit d'ailleurs un les communistes ont
été parmi les premiers à défier les
nazis mais parmi ses premiers aussi ces
pionniers de la résistance il ya eu
aussi des chrétiens
je trouvais ça intéressant de mettre en
lumière ses engagements oublié et puis
dé lever quelques statues aussi à des
gens qui se sont engagés très souvent
dans le secret dans la discrétion pour
libérer la france libérer la patrie et
ils l'ont fait pas toujours au nom de
leur foi mais en tout cas la foi est
constitutive de leur identité les a
pétri et les a conduits à ses
engagements
l'espérance est un risque à courir c'est
le titre de votre livre c'est un message
d'espoir aussi pour nous tous dans des
période si troublée
c'est cela je pense que ces grands
témoins encore une fois ils sont
obscures ils sont discrets ils sont ils
sont ils agissent dans la discrétion
dans le secret ont beaucoup de choses à
nous dire à notre époque que j'ai fait
j'en découvre et un belge ont trouvé un
autre rien et je me suis aperçu en fait
qui avait une espèce de chaînes comme ça
de deux ont pour appeler la la banalité
du bien c'est à dire des gens qui voient
là qui qui se sont engagés autour de
chez eux sans penser forcément à des
grands discours des uns des grands mots
mais
et qu'ils ont voilà combattu la barbarie
et surtout agi pour l'humanité merci
beaucoup jérôme cordelier je rappelle le
titre de votre livre l'espérance est un
risque à courir et il est publié aux
éditions calmann-lévy merci jérôme
bientôt une belle histoire maintenant
pour terminer ce grand jt des
territoires nous nous rendons en
martinique un nouveau maître de chai
officie désormais à l'habitation clément
et là bas la passation de la gestion de
ses 12000 fut de la marque s'est fait
sur près de 20 ans il n'en fallait pas
moins pour que julien timon originaire
du vauclin arrive à maturité
une rencontre avec lui qui a réalisé
malek de via à tv martinique sur place
pendant près de 20 ans julien timon et
robert péroné en cheminée côte à côte
arrivé en 2002 pour deux mois en tant
qu'agent de chez en intérim
julien ne se doute pas encore qu'ils
entament un véritable processus de
maturation vous arrivez ici savais pas
trop si c'est ce serait mon métier
aujourd'hui mais j'ai vite attiré
notamment avec manches et mon ancien
chef de service robert péroné qui m'a
quand même transmis cette passion on se
retrouvait souvent un symbole abh haut à
déguster à échanger je posais beaucoup
de questions et lui était toujours là
pour y répondre
c'est vrai que nous sommes nous avons
toujours été en contact direct que en
passant dans les sièges
discutions et puis naturellement sa
volonté d'évoluer dans le métier a
permis effectivement d'accueillir un peu
plus de reconnaissance et tombola
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est assez mûr
pour prendre le relais des lycéens
perpétuer donc le liront clément
contrôle des flux et des cuves choix des
barriques suivi des assemblages et
gestion d'une équipe depuis le début de
l'année julien timon et le maître de
chai de l'habitation clément
une véritable fierté pour ce veau kinois
et pour celui qui a transmis tout son
savoir faire une transmission qui aura
pris près de 20 ans une volonté de la
direction
nous avions vraiment la volonté que
cette passion ce professionnalisme
cette excellence que garantissait
monsieur peyronnet soit toujours garanti
par monsieur gilles hâtivement et tout
cela a été orchestré avec eux avec une
passation donc à la fois des
responsabilités mais aussi de la passion
du romao c'est martinique et même si
robert perrot net aujourd'hui à la
retraite il poursuit sa route aux côtés
de julien en intervenant ponctuellement
en tant que conseiller de l'équipe de
production
c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de l'avoir suivi sur
tv5monde et sur vos chaînes locales et
régionales
on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]